is that him
oh my god
[Music]
you look amazing oh my god
[Music]
are you okay yeah
oh don't worry about it baby oh my god
you smell so good you look so good
oh my god i'm so happy you're here
yeah me too come here
yeah i miss you so much i'm so happy
because
i am with you now thank you baby you are
loved
i got makeup
you want to meet them get your stuff
okay
hello this is the ed tiffany hello
how are you doesn't he smell amazing in
person
michael yeah let's meet mike okay i say
hi for micah
he's on purse duty
nice to meet you my friend good good
thank you yes sir are you okay
yep good perfect
[Music]
uh this uh surprise i see
i see tiffany and michael today with
rebecca
yeah i wanted to come and get you myself
only
but she told me today i'm coming with
you yeah that's so good yeah
perfect
the plane here everything good yeah
so good yes so good so comfortable yeah
i can't wait to show you the apartment
me too
i rate this always you you say this they
won't see
i mean zia is pretty much exactly what
we pictured
but he does just seem very nonchalant
he's just like yeah okay
yeah okay i don't know like i can't
really explain it you thought he'd be a
lot more
enthusiastic as he got here yeah it's
kind of like
it's weird
you